- Gmail's what I'm on now.
(car revs)
That's the, uh,
you got the most space for attachments.
Anyway.
- Thank you.
- Feel free to hit me up if
you remember that number.
I noticed you ain't write that down.
Damn, damn, damn.
(car revs)
That girl was fly, right?
- She all right.
But did you see that Liam Neeses movie
with them wolves though?
- The one with them big ass
wolves and Liam Neeses in it.
(tires screech)
- Liam Neeses is my (beep).
- Liam Neeson's straight
jacked up them wolves.
- Man, he (beep) them wolves up, man.
Shoot, man.
Hey, and don't even get
me started on that one
when they took this daughter.
- "Straight Tooken",
starring Liam Neeses.
Man, Liam Neeses on the phone,
like I have a certain set of skills.
Man, don't (beep) with Liam Neeses.
- Don't even try and be
rushing around Liam Neeses.
He'll take your arm and-
(Bald man screams)
- Killing a man.
Oh, did you see the second one though?
In the second one, the
Russians come after him,
and he (beep) them all up anyway.
- "Tooken Two",
starring the incomparable Liam Neeses
- Mmm hmm.
- That's my (beep)
- What about "Dark Man" though.
- No.
What about Liam Neeses in
some "Dark Man" though.
(beep)
- What about "Dark Man" with Liam Neeses.
- Face was changing up there.
- Homie was straight face changing.
Now that's just Liam Neeses
acting right there man.
- Straight up, I kid you
not academy award caliber,
classic Neeses.
- Seriously, I mean
like Neeses already need
to have a statue.
- Liam Neeses aint got none?
- He aint got no statue.
He aint got a statue.
- No, no no.
The Oscar goes to:
Liam Neeses, "Dark Man".
(beep) Face was changing!
- Mmm hmm.
- How hard is that?
- It aint hard dog.
It's not hard at all.
- Damn!
- It's stupid man.
- Battleship
(bald man screams)
Battleship
(bald man continues to scream)
Battleship!
- Liam Neeses straight
killed a robot boat.
Liam Neeses is my shiznit.
(Black haired man screams)
But you know who I like
as much as Neeses though?
- As much as Neeses?
Who?
- Bruce Willie.
(Black haired man screams)
- Bruce Willie is my (beep)
But what if they made a
movie with Liam Neeses
and Bruce Willie?
- Neeses and Willie!
- Willie and Neeses.
- Harder man, harder.
That would be
(both) MY SHIT!
(bodies explode)
- Yo,
- What's up?
- Game of Thrones though dog
- You all caught up?
- I totally binge watched that
whole thing last night, dog.
- So, It's cold blooded up in Westeros dog
- They killed my (beep) Ned.
- It's starts
- (both hum "Game of Thrones" theme tune)
- You aint seen that one coming did you?
- (beep) Hell no.
- Uh uh.
- Oh my god. I mean my
man was just there right,
and he got down there on the thing.
And I was like, I ain't worried.
They aint gonna kill my boy, Ned stark.
- Slit!
- And the plop.
I was like
(bald man screams)
- I told you they cold
blooded up in there.
- And then I was like, but that's okay.
because I still got my (beep) Khal Drogo
- Oh, big Dave Navarro.
- Yeah yeah yeah yeah
- Big Dave Navarro?
Yeah yeah.
(Bald man imitates guitar)
- Yeah, that dude picked
up some molten gold,
poured it on (beep) heads.
(bald man screams)
- I wanna sleep with my sister.
And he killed him right.
I mean he big like
Hercules and everything.
I'm like, you can't kill
Khal Drago with a papercut.
- An infected scratch?
- An infected scratch.
- But he got straight killed.
But you know who my favorite character is?
- Who's that dog? Who's that dog?
- Psss. Khaleesis.
- Khaleesi.
- You know I really
like them some Khaleesis
- But what about Khaleesis
straight up with them dragons.
Khaleesi's with them dragons.
And Khaleesis all like this
and then we talking about.
(Both imitate dragons)
Just straight roasting goats.
- Yo
- Oh my God.
- That's when they
start killing characters
left and right, dog.
- At the wedding?
- Yo, at the wedding.
- Rob Starks.
- What?
- His wife.
- They got his mom.
- Yo.
- (both) Killed, killed, killed, killed.
- That was a four for one dog.
- Four for one up there dog.
- That's a straight four for one.
- Four for one up in there.
- What about when they got wildlings girl,
talking about,
(black haired man imitates bow and arrow)
You know nothing Jon Snow.
(bald man imitates bow and arrow)
- (both) Killed!
- What about the hound dog?
- Yo, the hound dog.
- I've fallen down a hill.
(bald man screams)
Kill me! You've gotta kill me
- No
- (both) Killed!
- Slowly by omission.
- Bingo!
- Yo, what about my man Taiwan Lannisters.
- Taiwan Lannisters.
- Taiwan Lannisters stuff.
- Yo, my man talking about
I'm taking his (beep)
(bald man imitates weapon)
- Killed!
by his own son.
- What?
- The Dinkles?
- The Dinkles
- The Dinkles.
- (both) The Dinkles!
- The Dinkles is my jam.
- Aint nobody killed the Dinkles.
- The Dinkles is my jam, my
jelly, my peanut and my peanuts.
- Dinkles
- Dinkles though
(Both) DINKLES IS MY (BEEP)
(Apocalyptic music)
(electronic music)